let's go to the phones by which I mean
Discord and hear from some of those very
important people the people in the
audience you can find our Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord always use
proper show calling etiquette you get
right to your question you have good
audio and all of these different things
it's going to be a beautiful beautiful
day of calls I am sure I can just feel
it let's go today starting with Lucas
from Massachusetts Lucas from
Massachusetts welcome you're our first
caller let's hope for the best
hey David hi so now why can you hear me
I can't are you in a in an echoey where
are you in some kind of Turkish bath or
something all of my door of my dormitory
oh you're in the hall no one else here
beautiful what's going on
so there's a loaded question but not
long ago I watched a Thom Hartmann
segment in which he asked the question
if Trump's handling of covet should be
labeled to genocide I understand what
your thoughts are on that
yeah I got a similar question recently
about something related to trans and
genocide I you know I don't find it
super compelling to weigh in on that
because the the truth is you can make
these linguistic arguments one way or
another
um the the reality is that Trump handled
covid terribly and more people died than
would have if he had handled it better
but I don't know that any country
handled it perfectly and I think in
every country some people died that that
could have lived had it been handled
better we had limited information Etc
Trump was particularly bad so which is
the the genocide that anyone died that
didn't have to or that more than in
other countries or it's tough It's
really tough yeah I guess because Trump
there's evidence that he wanted more
blue people in blue states to die
um at the beginning
sorry you're saying it is what Trump did
in genocide because
he wanted more people from Blue State to
die isn't he on recording saying that I
might be remembering wrong but I'm not
aware that it was that he wanted people
from Blue states to die but he
ignorantly saw that the early infections
were in blue States because that's where
a lot of the big airports are and he
wrongly thought it wouldn't come to Red
States how wrong he was though
it was very wrong yeah anyway that's the
only question I had
um thank you and uh you haven't seen
this on the show all right Lucas from
Massachusetts thank you so much for the
call appreciate it